you're watching audrey there we're
bringing you the news that a journalist
for al jazeera network our correspondent
sharin abu akley has been shot in the
face and has died shortly afterwards
according to the palestinian health
ministry it happened apparently during
an israeli army raid in the janine town
in northern west bank nida ibrahim is in
ramallah in the occupied west bank nida
i want to ask you first of all how you
and the team
are reacting to the news this morning
we're here in al jazeera's offices in
ramallah
where if you can see the colleagues of
shireen at gathering there are
journalists also here coming everyone is
looking at this video
that shows the last moment
of her life
[Music]
she has been shot while she was covering
israeli weight in janine
and if you will pay attention to that
video i'm not sure if you can see
but even as she was shot
and you will see someone coming in now
trying to pull her from the scene
the gunshots continued
so it was really difficult even if she
had a chance to make it it was really
difficult to pull her
to get her the help she needed
and shortly after
she succumbed to her wounds in the
hospital
neither one can understand forgiveness
forgive me for interrupting you one can
understand
because we have heard from um
from stephanie how tightly knit
these teams can be how much like a
family
these teams on the ground can be
try if you can just talk to us what kind
of impact this is having on the team
i think
the pictures are speaking for themselves
right rob
people here
have lived with her you know these teams
go on long coverages they spend days and
days in the field so are like one family
we even got a message from children
yesterday asking
us to come to janine where she has been
based
her producer
who's here
he's been also a friend they go out
together
so you can see
and you can sense the closeness of their
relationship not only amongst al jazeera
family but also other journalists
working for other networks
because there's a feeling among
palestinian journalists
that they are targeted by the israeli
forces because they are carrying the
story because they are the messenger
of the israeli violations the attacks of
what's going on so here everyone feels
that they themselves
could be like shireen many of them if
you ask them they tell you that they've
been shot
by
live ammunition by rubber-coated steel
bullets
they've been hit by tear gas cancer so
as these people are concerned
the aim
is to prevent them from going to the
field
and covering we're talking about the
seasoned
journalists who knew the nuances of the
story who has been well versed
everywhere we go as al jazeera english
team we meet people who say oh yeah we
know shiri and she was there when we
were covering in janine in the past few
weeks
people were saying that she was one of
the first people to arrive after the
israeli invasion to the camp
and
that mark 20 years we marked the
anniversary of
just a few days ago 20 years ago when
the israeli army invaded the camp
technically raising the buildings there
to clamp down on the palestinian
fighters
someone not only is seasoned and knows
her story
she's also been
trying to learn she has never had enough
she wanted to learn new media she just
graduated with a diploma from bernstein
university she was showing us her phone
proudly uh showing us how she was
editing and using those softwares to
edit the phone she was very modest for
someone who was very well known very
professional
so
she was also telling us in janine that
she was learning hebrew she was reading
to us from israeli media israeli
narrative because often when you look at
stories there's a palestinian narrative
and there's an israeli narrative and
it's important for palestinians to get
their voice out there so it's important
for them to know what's going on or what
the israeli media is reporting to kind
of try and debunk it and say what really
happened let me take you to her office
she's been working here
she has an office this is
the empty office of shirin
this is where she reported on the story
you can see a lot of
honoring plaques for her
from several places
this is uh in regards to a committee
defending
the rights of palestinian refugees
remember we're just a few days from
marking the 74th anniversary of nakba
the 1948 displacement of more than 700
000 palestinians
by when israel
was created she was telling the story
for all of these decades
she has been someone who would rely on
to tell you the story she was a teacher
in berget university but she was also
also a student
she really wanted to focus on the human
element of the story she was someone
you'd feel comfortable talking to so i
guess that's why people opened up to her
talk to her
and she was able to carry their features
their stories
so that's why
we're seeing lots and lots of
people coming to
the bureau here's
rania who's besides herself she also she
always would tell me shireen shireen
she would know this let me call sharin
before we go to janine
i know you don't have words
and i'm sorry
but just one word
for sharing
well sir
we will everyone
here
has known her has
known how kind she is you might see them
now
engaged in the details now we hear that
they're gonna take her body for autopsy
people here say that they want to bring
her justice they want the world to know
what palestinian journalists and
palestinians are going through
nida there must be questions that
people like you and her colleagues ask
themselves when they're faced with a
situation like this about whether it's
worth carrying on whether it's worth
doing
this job and putting your life at risk
can you
encapsulate for us what the mood would
be moving forward do you think that
people are going to at least some of
them might say
i'm not doing this anymore
definitely isn't that the goal
i can tell you studying journalism in
brazil university my generation has
the generation that has been
young during the second and the father
want to study journalism because of
correspondence like sharing
like jivara buderi they wanted to tell
the world the story the way these
journalists did
so when they see an idol of theirs when
they see someone who's been shot when i
see someone like her who was just
commenting on my picture yesterday
just go just like that
how is that going to affect me trying to
go to janine again or to go to the west
bank again or
yeah of course
it's i can't i can't tell you how it's
going to affect me i'm still processing
i'm still in shock everyone here is
still in shock
[Music]
but definitely it's going to have an
impact on you you know what even if we
want to keep on telling the story what
about our families are they going to be
okay with us continuing doing this story
now this is not to say that palestinians
are safe and journalists are the ones
being targeted we are covering our story
we are covering the story of our people
of our families so it's not like if i'm
not a journalist i'm not going to be
targeted or killed we pass checkpoints
on a daily basis
and sometimes you see armed
israeli soldiers
uh uh directing their weapons at you
so
you think that that is not gonna
affect
us or like you know like that could
happen to us my point is that these
things could happen to us and excuse me
if i'm just
sometimes a class of words nida i
completely understand of course it has
only happened just within the last few
hours and we do appreciate that the team
still has to process as you say
everything that that is going on but i
do want to ask um nida just finally
we've seen the pictures of shireen's
body being taken in a procession through
the streets of janine um
what the and the crowds there have been
very significant what do you think the
reaction on the streets is going to be
to this
it's hard to expect how people are going
to react
she's a seasoned journalist she's been
very well known professional has touched
the hearts of many wherever we go we
hear that oh sharing was here oh she
didn't cover the story and from years
and years ago people in janine are
carrying her body now in honor of her
of her professionalism of the fact that
she died
telling the story
leader thank you very much indeed that
nida ibrahim talking to us from the
occupied west bank